[Musique]
notre invité fouille a un passé très
très lointain sa spécialité c'est
l'étude de l'os des crânes des vertèbres
l'analyse des dents il a passé une bonne
partie de sa vie à rechercher des
fossiles vieux de plusieurs millions
d'années heureusement pour lui et pour
nous il en a trouvé il a même trouvé des
bouts de squelettes qui ont fait sa
renommée internationale lui si ça vous
dit bien quelque chose eh bien c'est lui
il fait partie de ceux qui ont découvert
l'australopithèque star qui a
révolutionné le monde de la
paléontologie
tout cela on va l'évoqué bien sûr car
c'est toute sa vie mais on va essayer de
chercher plus on va essayer de fouilles
et nous aussi de comprendre cette
passion pour les ossements qui l'animent
depuis qu'il est tout petit bienvenue
dans un monde un regard bienvenue yves
coppens merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation ici dans le dôme tournon du
sénat je le disais paléontologues paléo
anthropologue auteur d'origine de
l'homme origines d'un homme et de le
savant le fossile et le prince vous
m'avez dit un jour en interview faire
étalage de ma vie personnelle n'est pas
dans mon habitude
et pourtant nous on a envie de
comprendre on a envie de savoir ce qui
vous a mené à cette passion pour la
paléontologie je crois que c'est très
tôt que ça vous prend oui vous savez
d'abord on ne sait pas quand on est
petit corps ça se présente quand ça se
passe mais j'ai des souvenirs en
cherchant bien dans ma grosse mémoire
c'est mon boulot la mémoire quand même
j'ai des souvenirs qui remonte
probablement à 6 ou 7 ans quoi donc
quand même tout petit et je pense que ce
moment là il n'y a pas de vocation bien
bien à ça des médias l'imaginaire de
l'enfance qui s'épanouit et l'imaginaire
quand on s'aperçoit que sous vos pieds
dans l'enfouît il ya beaucoup de restes
d'informations sur ce qui s'est passé
l'imaginaire ce en ce qui nous concerne
en tout cas se développer en souterrain
et vos premières fouilles voulait mener
chez vous en bretagne et vous avez deux
surnoms vous élevez coco fossiles et le
père l'abri
facile parce que j'étais fasciné
forcément c'est dans la continuité par
les fossiles et la brique parce que je
fouillais et comme je pense quand vous
fouillez dans des régions comme le sud
de la bretagne où j'étais font
rencontrer d'abord les période médiévale
par ordre d'importance par ordre
d'ancienneté et ensuite le romain lauga
de romain qui a été très important
puis ensuite le gaulois ensuite les
litiges etc or j'ai trouvé bien sûr des
sites romains hors des sites romains
cette déconstruction c'est pas très
vieux et de milan donc les constructions
ce sont des briques pour construire la
maison des briques pour couvrir la
maison et je rapportais toujours des
tonnes de débris que chez moi que j'ai
d'ailleurs offerte au musée local qui
doit pas savoir qu'en faire et donc les
copains de gentiment m'appelait le père
la brique parce que j'avais toujours une
brique dans la poche alors il ya des
briques à bord comme ça qu'ils
s'appellent de taigu laissé pour
construire et puis allez brigue ronde
qui s'appelle d un bris csc pour couvrir
et ça j'en ai plein quoi j'ai de quoi
construire une villa si ça vous fait
plaisir et ligne villa romaine les
décennies plus tard vous l'avez toujours
cette même passion ah oui absolument je
ne sais jamais étant jamais amoindri
mais toujours dans l ain a évolué
forcément non allez allez allez
permanente elle est permanente et
maintenant elle dira sans doute jusqu'au
bout un peu pourquoi ils s'arrêteraient
et je travaille tout le temps mais
évidemment beaucoup moins sur le terrain
d'abord parce que je vois pas très clair
ensuite parce que je marche moins bien
mais la passion et permet en permanence
vous pouvez pas vous imaginer le chez
vous quand est-ce que ça devient sérieux
que ça devient une vraie vocation
ça devient sérieux quand ça devient
professionnel quoi mais à quel moment
pour vous ben c'est devenu professionnel
en mouvement rouge je me suis engagé
étant étudiant dans des chantiers de
fouilles et caen et c'était des
chantiers de fouilles aussi en bretagne
parce que j'ai commencé par l'université
de rennes avant de passer à la sorbonne
et à l'université de rennes il y avait
des cours de préhistoire auxquels je me
suis tout de suite inscrit et puis le
préhistorien de l'époque conduisait des
les chantiers de fouilles et l'aja était
fou hier j'étais petite main au contact
de la matière de la tiers ça c'est un
déclic des chantiers superbe superbe jeu
raconte rapidement un quand même qui me
tient à coeur c'était juste mes 20 ans
juste mes 20 ans et c'était à carnac
harnes c'est une petite île du nord du
finistère il y avait une petite butte on
était trois trois copains et donc on a
fait d'abord le plan de la butte sur le
plan topographique c'est tout donc on se
dit c'est une petite colline où c'est
artificiel et puis on a fait un trou
plutôt du côté de l'est et on est tombé
dans une sorte petite fausse petite
fosse avec td pierre levet et des
pierres couvrant la fosse on a fouillé
ça et on a trouvé quelques bouts de
poterie il y avait un petit mur d'un
côté un petit peur de l'autre alors on a
sondé et le petit mur d'un côté et est
accru de l'autre côté s'est accrue et si
wap sur les trois qui étaient le plus
mal ce bordel où les autres savaient pas
ce qu'ils sont devenus et c'est moi qui
suis passé le premier à travers ce trou
et je suis rentré dans une salle comme
celle ci l'a une salle en dominant doom
de 7000 à nez avec des pierres en
encorbellement et c'était c'était une
sépulture collective et c'était la
première fois depuis sept mille ans que
quelqu'un on sera là dedans quand on a
20 ans et qu'on a ce genre de deux
d'anniversaire c'est formidable et
détails intimes ma maman m'a dit quand
même porter maintenant tu revenir la
maison sinon c'est vous qui venez sur le
terrain donc mes parents sont venus dans
cette petite île de carnac pour voir le
sapin et thales pour voir là la première
coupole de ma jeunesse quoi est ce que
vous avez ressenti ce genre d'émotions
cette même émotion lors de vos filles en
afrique je crois que 1960 a été aussi un
tournant vous êtes partis au tchad là
aussi ça a été deux des moments de
fouiller de recherche et de découverte
émouvante absolument mais le sage et de
deux sorties découvertes d'abord la
découverte d'un autre ailleurs et en
l'occurrence celle de l'afrique noire
d'afrique tropicale qui m'a enchanté à
laquelle dans lequel je rêvais depuis
longtemps et qui a correspondu tout à
fait mes rêves d'une part et d'autre
part le terrain quoi j'ai allié au fonds
la recherche archéologique et le bonheur
d'aller me balader à travers la terre
entière et j'ai trouvé des quantités de
choses et comme vous le dites comme vous
l'évoquez en 61 des 61 alors jeté 1 60
au tchad j'ai eu un premier crâne de
fossiles qui est moins vieux que je ne
pensais au départ je mets qui quand même
a été une sorte de passeport quoi parce
que international j'avais dire quand
vous étiez dans la cour des grands la
vous fait une découverte majeure que
vous êtes toujours depuis que l'on vous
suit un petit peu mais de loin et puis
que vous arrivez avec un petit crâne
fossile très fossilisés et très
fossilisé avec encore du grès partout
sur les bras tout d'un coup le l'america
un regard j'ai été invité dans une
fondation américaine
les chercheurs d'or le reste de
l'afrique chercheurs britanniques du
kenya l'afrique du sud ont honte un
regard j'ai été invité et partout et
puis une fois invité partout vous êtes
dedans comme vous dites non dans la cour
ou d'un oui dans la classe des grands
anciens et puis ensuite vous faites
votre chemin et vous devenez anciens
vous même vous savez si c'est encore
possible ce genre de recherche dans ces
zones africaines où il ya une forme
d'insécurité pour j'imagine les
chercheurs occidentaux vous savez si
c'est encore possible
dans certaines régions c'est toujours
possible même mais c'est plus dangereux
non pas de se faire tuer mais surtout de
se faire de prisonniers qui est ce que
quand on est quand on est fait
prisonnier c'est une monnaie de change
c'est une façon de parler de soi et
c'est d'autant plus dangereux qu'on met
du coup ça freine les chercheurs ça
freine aussi du coup les découvertes
bien sûr forcément c'est un drame pour
votre science forcément oui bien sûr à
plusieurs reprises par exemple boechat
moi j'ai cessé d'y travailler en 66 et
c'est dans ces années là un petit peu
plus tard que françoise claustré a été
faite prisonnière et que les restes et
quand même trois ans dans le tibesti
trois ans aux mains de gens que je
connaissais en fait que j'avais num plus
jeunes dans le tibesti quoi ils
célèbrent et je le connaissais bien
qu'ils étaient devenus après président
de la république du tchad et au en
ethiopie il ya eu aussi un changement de
régime le l'empereur que j'ai bien connu
c'est le mans l'empereur jeu c'était
presque un grand père pour moi c'était
drôle nos rapports étaient était à la
fois protocolaire et critique familiaux
et
l'empereur a été
destitué puis après il a été fait
prisonnier puis après il a disparu il a
été probablement exécutés et s'est
installé un régime autoritaire avec un
col là il s'appelait mengistu et il ya
eu 10 ans d'arrêt de recherche avant la
reprise mais oui on est bien sûr soumis
aux conditions politiques de différents
pays avec un long travail je voudrais
vous montrer un document yves coppens un
document qui nous a été donnée est
prêtée par les archives nationales qui
sont nos partenaires pour cette émission
un monde un regard je vous le donne je
vais le lire pour les gens qui nous
écoutent c'est l'arrêté napoléonien de
nomination d' edouard lartet à la chaire
de paléontologie du muséum d'histoire
naturelle le 31 mars 1869 alors edouard
lartet c'est une figure majeure de la
paléontologie je ne vous apprends rien
paléontologues préhistorien français du
19e c'est qu'il a découvert le premier
grand singe fossiles c'est ça sa
révolution me tiens cela qu'il a
révolutionné le votre science oui enfin
c'est quand même très impressionnant
bien sûr dans l'est du pays il a fouillé
enfin c'est être un amateur mais un
amateur éclairé on dit un amateur qui
travaillaient vraiment beaucoup qui
avait qui étaient très provincial alors
je dis pas ça méchamment mais il avait
un peu ce complexe surtout à l'époque
plus de
d'être en province alors que paris
dominait la situation y compris
scientifiques mais ils venaient à paris
souvent il est en rapport avec les
professeurs 12e qu'il fréquentait et qui
ce qu'il apprenait aussi beaucoup de
choses et lui fouillait dans son dans
son sud ouest et avec avec grand succès
et le fait de découvrir le le premier
prix m même ici en europe le premier
primate fossile a été un grand coup et
évidemment comme chaque découvreur de
primates on a l'impression qu'on
découvre l'origine de l'homme tout de
suite à chaque fois mais justement
l'idée que l'homme descendait du singe
c'est en partie lui
c'est en partie
d'abord buffon et puis après bien des
gens avant d'ailleurs un certain vannini
au xvième siècle qui du coup lui s'est
fait brûler vous dis pas n'importe quoi
et n'importe quand et puis ensuite
bichon et puis ensuite
la marque et puis ensuite darwin et c
c'est à dire que le lien de la grande
filiation de toute l'histoire de la vie
toute l'histoire de la vie elle s'est
bien installée jusqu'à la découverte de
l'adn qui a confirmé songez que le petit
virus qui nous embêtent en ce moment il
a un adn comme nous avons un adn le sien
est plus simple de notre plus compliqué
mais il n'empêche que ça signifie que ce
petit virus et nous nous sommes cousins
tous toute cette histoire de la vie et
l'histoire d'une famille alors des
cousins plus ou moins lointain mais
évidemment ils sont d'autant plus proche
que qui sont primates et les primates
les plus proches surtout ces primaires
fossiles et je voudrais insister l'un
sur une histoire la découverte de
l'artiste ça veut dire mis en scène
enfin peu importe mais du point de vue
géologique ça s'appelle du miocène y ait
assez de moyens miocène supérieur c'est
à dire que c'est une cohue autour de 15
millions d'années 15 millions d'années
et à 15 millions d'années le tout le sud
de l'europe est tropical actuellement il
ya le changement climatique avec la
chaleur qui monte pas trop aujourd'hui
mais quand même à chaleur keane qui
grimpe et cette chaleur qui g va faire
de notre probable en une nouvelle fois
une nouvelle fois c'est déjà connu des
géologues une nouvelle fois de tout ce
sud européen une zone tropicale donc on
va peut-être voir les sages revenir et
et nous-mêmes changer de couleur puisque
notre adaptation à un ensoleillement
plus fort exigera une couche de mélanine
des drôles tout ça non alors oui et on y
revient peut-être sur cette question de
l'environnement qui joue sur nous
humains mais je voudrais revenir sur
cette question de l'homme et du singe
l'un de vos confrères le palais montre
aux autres paléoanthropologue pascal
picq a poussé un coup de gueule un jour
dans le monde en disant ceci l'homme ne
descend pas du singe il a des ancêtres
communs avec lui c'est très différent et
pourtant cette phrase elle circule que
l'homme descend du singe on a tous en
tête ce schéma de l'homme qui a faim de
jeu aux singes qui se redresse
progressivement pour devenir homme est
ce que l a fait du mal cette cette idée
populaire que l'homme descendait du
singe il est éloigné des croyants de la
science par exemple ça ça à chaque un
petit peu mais à partir du moment où les
appels de primates qui sont les sages
quoi faut pas se voiler la face à partir
du moment où les primates commence il ya
80 millions d'années
et que toute cette histoire est une
histoire de singe
jusqu'à la différence entre les
chimpanzés et les humains vers 10
millions d'années toute cette histoire
là est une histoire de sages ont du
primate encore une fois mais vous
l'entendez que s'éloigne des gens de
modulation ses désirs mais non mais moi
je descend pas du singe il ya ce
discours créationnistes qui dit non
l'homme a été créé tel quel par dieu on
voit comment il est évident que la la la
voie de la science nous dit bien sûr que
nous sommes par un départ en d2 tous les
singes de la terre et que nous
descendons bien sûr deux singes nous ne
descendons pas du singe parce que dans
la tête des gens depuis longtemps c'est
le chimpanzé dont nous ne descendons pas
du chimpanzé parce que les chimpanzés
sont des cousins mais nous descendons
d'un sage de 10 millions d'années ça
veut dire qu'on est sur du sage je
pousserai le coup de gueule contraire si
si si nous descendons bel et bien du
sahel faut pas encore une fois
vous n'êtes donc pas remis je le disais
en introduction ce qu'ils ont découvert
lucie le 30 novembre 1974 je crois en
ethiopie et vous avez dit un jour
trouver lucie fut miraculeux pour le
ceux qui n'y connaissent rien comme moi
explique ennour et expliquez nous
pourquoi l'uci a été à ce point une
découverte miraculeuse
parce que ce sont ceux sont enfin ceci
est une très humaine encore une humaine
une prime d'un peu plus de 3 milliards
donnés prix humaine pourquoi d'abord
parce qu'elle marchait et grimpait c'est
ça c'est ça parce que l'humain à
d'autres caractéristiques qui seront le
développement du cerveau ce qu'elle n'a
pas qu'ils sont le développement des
voies respiratoires supérieures canapa
et puis qui sont leurs formations ont
des dents parce qu'il ya un changement
de régime et que nous mangeons de la
viande à elle donc l'uci est une pré
humaines et au moment de ces primes
c'est à dire un peu plus de trois
millions d'années que l'on connaissait
depuis 1925 1924 mai 1924 1925 tous ces
prêts humains là on en trouvait à bout
de mâchoire par ici un bout de dent par
là un bout de crâne par ici un bout de
fémur par là c'est tout tandis que là
tout d'un coup dans le même secteur de
manière une miraculeuse surprend le mot
on trouve 1 2 3 4 5 6 52 52 restent du
même individu et 52 restent du même
individu étant donné qu'on est
symétrique
quand on a un bout de deux demis russe
ce droit on fait l'humérus gauche quand
on a un bout du tibia gauche ont fait le
tibia droit et donc on a reconstitué la
silhouette du personnage en question et
tout d'un coup dans la tête des gens et
dans la tête aussi des scientifiques au
lieu de reconstituer comme ça à partir
d'une mâchoire un personnage on peut
reconstituer quelqu'un de manière assez
vraisemblable donc le petit personnage
de lucy est devenu d'un coup vivent
autrement dit odyssée la plus complète
c'est pas vrai mais je dirais une
bannière plus modestes c'était à ce
moment là tu as moins à -5 ont placé des
primes est un mythe elle est devenue un
mythe pour l'opinion publique est ce qu
elle a aussi bousculé les codes
l'homme préhistorique le fait que ce
soit une femme est ce que ça a pu
choquer le fait qu'elle soit une femme
sûrement joué dans sa réputation je veux
dire que le fait qu'elles soient petites
qu'elles soient anciennes qu'elle soit
exotique qu'elle soit reconstituable le
fait que quel soit entre guillemets à
l'orgie de l'humanité ou pas loin le
fait qu'elle soit en effet une femelle
et le fait qu'elle ait aussi ce nom que
beaucoup de gens connaissent tout cela
est intervenue est en fait à terme
aujourd'hui elle est moins importante
qu'elle n'était au moment la découverte
puisque on a trouvé plus vieux on a
trouvé plus complète mais ceci dit elle
est en effet resté le symbole est en ce
sens est en l'icône de l'origine de
l'âme ça nous a facilité beaucoup la
tâche d'enseignement la tâche de
l'éducation la tâche de diffusion de la
science de l'information lorsque je
voudrais qu'on parle aussi
d'environnement vous en avez déjà un
tout petit peu parlé yves coppens peu de
gens le savent mais c'est vous qui est à
l'origine de la charte de
l'environnement adossée à notre
constitution c'est votre commission ce
sont vos travaux qui ont servi de base à
l'élaboration de cette charte celle qui
a donné en tout cas à l'environnement
une existence constitutionnel c'est
jacques chirac qui vous a confié cette
mission est ce que c'est une source de
fierté c'est un document majeur encore
aujourd'hui pour pour nous est ce que
c'est une source de fierté une étape
importante de votre parcours cette aide
est à point c'est une source de fierté
oui en ce sens que je n'étais pas du
tout préparés à faire ce genre de choses
je suis arrivé comme un zombie dans ce
monde de la politique et en plus quand
vous êtes nommé président d'une
commission quand vous arrivez au
ministère de l'écologie en l'occurrence
écologie et développement durable vous
vous apercevez que vous êtes président
de rien du tout d'une commission qu'il
vous faut mettre sur pied vous même donc
je suis parti de zéro en quelque sorte
et on se sens oui c'était une certaine
fierté d'autant plus mais vous aviez une
sensibilité écologique pourquoi vous
confier cette mission jacques chirac je
ne sais pas
faire état non non il aurait fallu
demander à chérac non non moi j'ai
travaillé en effet comme je travaille
ceci paléontologues je travaille sur les
restes humains bien sûr c'est en ce sens
que je suis paléo anthropologues oui
mais je travaille aussi sur les restes
animaux qui accompagne alors les restes
animaux c'est de l'information sur
l'environnement et l'environnement dans
une intervention sur le climat et c'est
donc j'avais travaillé sur les paléo
environnement mais c'est tout et en
l'occurrence je crois que c'est roselyne
bachelot qui a souhaité que je préside
cette commission c'est elle qui m'a
appelé un jour j'ai traîné les pieds et
finalement le lendemain à son chef de
cabinet j'ai dit non et puis chirac a
pris le téléphone depuis finalement il
m'a eu si vous ne vous dit rien non
c'était sincère cet engagement pour
l'environnement de la part de jacques
chirac d'après vous c'était
c'était sincère c'était un peu politique
enfin forcément quand on est politique
on fait des actions politiques c'était
un peu faire faire tourner vers la
droite l'environnement qui auparavant
étaient un peu à gauche hugo autant que
je sache pas ce que je suis assez nul
dans ce genre d'histoire mais c'était en
même temps très sincère très sincère et
ce qu'il a souhaité c'était sympathique
pour pour moi c'est que cette charte
soit agrandi à l'europe et puis
finalement un grand dit au monde entier
mais il est mort avant de réussir alors
ce qui a été impressionnant pour moi
c'est pas de mener ce boulot moi j'ai
l'habitude enfin vous ça ça me plaît je
pensais à bras le corps et puis je le
fais vraiment et on a travaillé dix mois
de façon vraiment intense mais pas
imaginer j'ai eu un contact avec à peu
près de 500000 personnes à travers la
france alors ça fait pas
66 millions mais ça fait quand même pas
mal et à terme ce qui m'a beaucoup
impressionné c'est que cette charte
ensuite
chirac s'en est emparée dé passer devant
les chambres y compris le sénat bien sûr
et puis ensuite on a été un peu amendé
puis ensuite elle est arrivée devant le
congrès et ensuite elle est entrée dans
la constitution française alors en ce
sens oui ils sont si fiers d'être dans
la constitution française en un mot tout
de même elle c'est à dire que nous nous
inquiétons à tort de ce réchauffement
climatique est ce que vous avez
confiance en l'humain pour s'adapter à
tout changement climatique bien sûr
mais on se parle à tort dans la croix
s'inquiète se dit par ailleurs parce
qu'il ya un vrai échange automatique le
vent du changement climatique changement
de température ça serait un peu long
mais le le changement climatique fait
fondre le voyant le groenland ces trois
mètres de glace et le groenland fait
qu'aujourd'hui la mer monte enfin c'est
pas la peine de vous dire où on sait
bien les gens qui sont au bord de la
côte voit la cote s'effondrer et voilà
la mer gagner sur les habitations qui
sont le pied dans l'ovni front d'avoir
le temps de s'adapter
oui parce que oui parce que notre
adaptation elle est à la fois biologique
et en ce sens et c'est long mais elle
est aussi culturel quand même depuis
trois millions d'années on a inventé la
culture grâce à notre petit cerveau qui
s'est bien développé et cette salle
culturelle peut avoir la parade alors ce
que ce que moi je pense je ne préconise
pas parce que je suis pas compétent mais
je trouve qu on est un petit peu on se
bute un petit peu addition du co2 le co2
ça a été notre mur on est au bord du co2
on ne pense que co2 on ne pense que
l'histoire de carbone alors que l'on
donnerait de il me semble on donnerait
de l'argent un peu plus d'argent à la
science la science trouverez peut-être
un moyen de casser la cette fichue
molécules de co2 et ça ferait du coût du
carbone songez que enfin pour moi qui
suis simplement observateurs changé que
j'ai entendu à la télé puisque je suis
pas dans ce monde de l'astronomie j'ai
entendu qu'on avait envoyé une petite un
petit véhicule sur sur mars quand même
et ses petits véhicules sur mars qu'est
ce qu'il a fait il a attrapé du co2
l'atmosphère de mars à des commodes bas
sur la terre quelqu'un leur donner il a
il a chopé le co2 et il en a fait de
l'oxygène alors pas beaucoup et puis ça
doit être très cher puis ça doit être
très compliqué pour le moment mais je
pense que la science peut trouver
d'autres solutions en tout cas on a sous
le nez un petit véhicule de rien du tout
qui nous fait ça enfin su donner c'est
beaucoup dire là haut sur mars et puis
on en parle et personne ne relève ni sur
la donc j'ai l'impression que le co2
c'est une espèce de de butoir on est le
nez dessus c'est ça puisque obtenait en
mathématiques s'appelle le pont aux ânes
selanne qui refuse de passer de la fij
rivière et en mathématiques qui a été
hors m que sur lequel sur lequel les
certains jeunes but et ils ne vont pas
au delà quoi yves coppens eu quelques
photos à vous montrer celle-ci d'abord
c'est le sait l'un de vos confrères
c'était le paléontologue kenyan richard
liquide décédé début janvier 2022
paléoanthropologue sans diplôme et c'est
vous je crois qu'il avait appelé le plus
grand découvreur de fossiles de tous les
temps c'est de vous que vient cette
expression le concernant moi c'est un
grand personnage au départ en 63 il
voulait pas du tout faire la recherche
de ses parents pharma là aussi c'est
comme mon père c'est comme une balle sur
l'alimentaire quoi il voulait pas du
tout suivre la voie de ses parents qui
fuyaient déjà beaucoup aidés étaient
déjà fameux il voulait mettre sur pied
sa propre organisation de safari puis
c'est tout officiellement il a lille a
eu le virus il a attrapé oui et puis il
a fait de la fin des merveilles une
version brillant et les gens courageux
chapeau un trésor une deuxième photo
pour vous une photo de vous avec nicolas
sarkozy et carla bruni à l'occasion des
70 ans de la découverte la grotte de
lascaux je vois sourire en voyant cette
photo c'est nicolas sarkozy là encore un
président qui vous nomme en 2010
président du conseil scientifique chargé
de la conservation de la grotte de
lascaux quels souvenirs vous gardez de
cette visite c'est d'abord le
titre et le bouleau correspondant de
deux présidents de la grotte de lascaux
président du conseil scientifique de
répondre à ce qu'on m'a beaucoup
intéressé j'ai mené sa com comme la
charte donc là vous avez dit oui avec
plaisir à bras le corps pendant pendant
sept ans et puis j'étais donc chargé de
faire descendre dans la vraie grotte les
autorités donc j'ai fait descendre
d'abord faudrait limiter rang puis
ensuite mitterrand et puis ensuite
nicolas sarkozy et puis ensuite aurélie
filippetti voilà mais le joueur et la
descente de sarkozy c'était très
intéressant parce que on arrive tous les
deux dans avec eux sa femme et on
n'arrive plus tous les trois dans dans
la grotte et il me dit c'est fou mieux
c'est pourquoi vous parler doucement à
elle me dit en effet oui vous voyez que
c'est à son mieux que c'est à
sainte-feyre vous est pris au piège à me
dit je sais comme comme dans une dans un
temple une une église bousquet c'est
vraiment une bonne nouvelle quand on
découvre une grotte comme celle là où
c'est un peu la condamner de fait
puisque on va y faire des recherches on
y fait entrer l'homme et l'oxygène et
qui va potentiellement l'abîmé oui parce
que on était assez innocent à l'époque
où ça a été découvert en 1940 et puis le
le
propriétaire de l'un de l'endroit a
voulu offrir ce qui était bien sa grotte
au public et donc il il a enlevé son
j'ai mille mètres cubes qui faisait un
bouchon à l'entrée de la grotte donc une
grotte qui est préservée comme une
espèce de bulle à l'intérieur de la
terre bulls table du même coup avec
une entrée qui s'était effondré et une
entrée tout d'un coup en louvre on
enlève mille mètres cubes alors que la
grotte fait 3000 mètres cubes c'est
effrayant tout d'un coup on laisse
entrer la pollution le froid la halle à
l'humilité enfin on change complètement
le l'histoire biologique de l'intérieur
de la grotte donc c'est normal qu'il y
ait eu des risques et c'est ça que moi
personnellement et puis beaucoup
d'autres vraiment ont tenté de rattraper
avec succès parce qu'on a refermé au
front yves coppens et une dernière
question en lien avec ce lieu dans
lequel nous sommes aujourd'hui nous
sommes entourés de quatre statues qui
représentent chacune une vertu la
sagesse la prudence la justice et
l'éloquence laquelle vous parle le plus
en dix mois sa sagesse mais prudence
justice éloquence oui c'est le singe f
pourquoi parce que ça permet de faire
beaucoup de choses ça n'empêche pas
l'audace avec avec avec la prudence qui
convient moi j'ai toujours enfin me
philippe hamoir par exemple mais mais
dans mon existence j'ai je crois a été
très adaptable très ouvert très
disponible très disponible c'est
important le truc curieux ça va de soi
un chercheur qui n'est pas curieux ne
sait pas aller chercher et il m'est
arrivé beaucoup beaucoup de choses et
beaucoup de choses extraordinaires
extravagantes même parfois parce que
j'ai saisi ces occasions qui m'était
offerte tout en mesurant quand même le
les risques c'est pas une lutte où toute
folie mais quand même c'est toute audace
merci infiniment yves coppens d'avoir
été notre invité dans un monde un regard
merci d'avoir répondu favorablement à
notre invitation
on se retrouve très vite sur public
sénat
[Musique]